now their defense which is underrated
includes linebacker Jaylon Smith a guy
who tore an ACL in the Fiesta Bowl in
early 2016 first day of January in that
Notre Dame Ohio State game lost out on
15 million or so when he plunged into
round 2 didn't play at all as a rookie
he was in a position where he was under
contract for one more year plus not
eligible for the franchise tag or
unrestricted free agency he was eligible
for a restricted free agency and that
means that he wasn't gonna make much
money over the next two years he traded
the next two years of expected revenue
in for a long-term deal with 19 million
fully guaranteed at signing 35 million
total guarantee with injury guarantee on
top of it a great deal for a guy who
plays a very violent position a guy with
a bad injury history a guy who was one
play away at any given moment from
having another career possibly ending at
a minimum career to railing type of an
injury and he did the smart thing he
took the money and you know you can say
well he's a better player than that he
should have held out for more well you
know what sometimes you wait for more
and you do suffer that injury and you
never get the money and it's very easy
to have that that conversation in a
vacuum it's another thing to say when
that money is on the table sorry I want
more so I'm not gonna take it
Jaylon Smith took the payday that he
never got when he's coming out in the
draft and now he can build on his career
from there and he did commit this is an
important detail to remember because
it's been called a five-year extension
it's not a five-year extension it's a
six-year extension of his current
contract it has him signed and committed
to the Cowboys through 2025 and as a
practical matter the commitment the
Cowboys are committed to him for the
next two years after 2020 it becomes a
year-to-year proposition and maybe they
keep him maybe they don't maybe they try
to negotiate the contract maybe they
don't but the bottom line is this Jaylon
Smith took the money because it was the
smart thing for him to do for the
Cowboys it was the smart thing for them
to lock that deal up at a below market
value rate now so they can turn their
attention back to the guys who want
market value the question is are they
going to use what Jaylon Smith did as
leverage to get these other guys
stop demanding market value the
staredown will continue with Ezekiel
Elliott Amari Cooper and dak Prescott
and we'll see if all three of them or
any of them end up signing a new
contract before the regular season
begins that's it for this edition of pft
ot we'll see you back here tomorrow with
an all-new pft live Sims we'll be back
and we will be getting you ready for
week 3 of the preseason because it
begins Thursday night great time of the
year because football is back not real
football real football is back in only
15 days and we can't wait for that
thanks for your continued support and
we'll see you here on Thursday
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports